[音乐]
军事司法统一法典规定，任何军官若将士兵送上战场却未配备武器，将被军事法庭审判。对学生也应有类似的保护，因为学生不应在缺乏沟通能力的情况下走向人生。
你人生的成功很大程度上取决于你的说话能力、写作能力以及你思想的质量，按此顺序。我知道我能在这方面成功，因为沟通的质量，即你的说话和写作，主要由这个公式决定。这取决于你拥有多少知识，你对这些知识进行了多少练习，以及你的天赋。注意，天赋这一项非常小。
真正重要的是你知道什么。这一点是几十年前我在太阳谷滑雪时突然领悟到的。我听说那是名人周末，其中一位名人是玛丽·露·雷顿，著名的奥运体操运动员，她在跳马项目中得过满分十分。我听说她滑雪是新手，所以当合适时机到来时，我朝新手坡看去，看到一位年轻女子，当她失去平衡时，她这样做了。我说那一定是她，那一定是那位体操运动员。但随后我想到，我比她滑雪好得多，而她是奥运选手，不仅是普通奥运选手，还是杰出的奥运选手，而我滑雪更好是因为我有知识，有练习，而她只有天赋。
所以如果你有足够的知识，你可以比那些有天赋的人表现得好得多。这就是我今天的目标。这是我的承诺：今天你将看到一些例子，你可以将这些放入你的演讲技巧库中。也许其中一些例子、某些技巧，甚至只有一个，会成为让你获得工作的那个。这是一个非常非线性的过程，你永远不知道它会在何时发生。但这就是我的承诺，在接下来的60分钟结束时，你将接触到许多想法，其中一些你会融入自己的技能库，它们将确保你获得最大机会，让你想法被听众重视和接受。
为了做到这一点，我们必须有一条参与规则，那就是不使用笔记本电脑，不使用手机。所以如果你们能关闭它们，我就开始。有些人问为什么会有这条规则，答案是：我们人类只有一个语言处理器。如果你的语言处理器忙于浏览网页或阅读邮件，你就会分心，更糟糕的是，你还会打扰周围的所有人。研究表明了这一点。更糟的是，如果我看到这里或那里有打开的笔记本电脑，我会很抓狂，表现也会变差。这样就确保你们所有专心听讲的朋友不会得到他们来听的差的表演。好了，开场白就到这里，我们开始吧。
首先当然要谈的是如何开场。有些人认为开场讲个笑话是合适的，我不推荐这样做，原因是在演讲开始时，人们还在收起笔记本电脑，正在适应你的说话参数和声音参数，他们还没有准备好听笑话，所以效果不好，通常会冷场。相反，你应该以“赋能承诺”开始，你要告诉人们他们在这一小时结束时将知道他们在开始时不知道的东西。这就是赋能承诺，也是他们来听讲的原因。比如，在这个60分钟结束时，你将知道一些你现在不知道的演讲技巧，而在这些技巧中，有一个会改变你的人生。是的，这就是赋能承诺，这是最好的开场方式。
现在我已经简单谈了如何开场，我想给你一些我演讲时总是会考虑的要点示例。第一个要点是，最好在主题上循环，绕一圈再绕一圈。有人说，告诉他们你想告诉他们的，再告诉他们一遍，然后告诉他们第三遍，好像人们不聪明似的。但原因是，有很多原因，其中一个是在任何时刻，大约20%的人会走神，不管是什么讲座。所以如果你想确保每个人都能听懂的概率高，你需要说三遍。所以循环是我演讲时总是考虑的事情之一。
我想到的另一件事是，在解释我的想法时，我想建一个栅栏围住它，这样它就不会被误解成别人的想法。所以如果你来自火星，我教你什么是拱门，我可能会说，那是拱门，那不要被误认为是其他东西，有些人可能以为是拱门，但这不是，那不是拱门。我在我的想法周围建栅栏，以便它能区别于别人的想法。所以从更技术的意义上讲，我可能会说，我的算法可能看起来与琼斯的算法相似，除了他的是指数级的，而我的线性的。这就是在给你的想法建栅栏，这样人们就不会混淆它与其他想法的关系。这个示例清单上的第三件事是口头表达的想法。
标点符号，这里的想法是，因为人们会偶尔走神，需要重新跟上思路，所以你需要提供一些地标性的时刻，告诉大家现在是重新跟上来的好时机。所以在这场演讲中，我可能会说一些这样的内容。
这是我的提纲。我们首先要讲的是如何开始，然后我们会处理这四个例子。在这四个例子中，我已经讲了第一个想法是循环，第二个想法是构建，现在第三个
想法是语言上的标点。所以我在列举，我在提供数字，让你感觉到演讲中有接缝，你可以重新跟上。好了，现在我们进展顺利，既然我们进展顺利，你能猜到第四个想法
可能是什么吗？一个帮助人们重新跟上思路的
想法？没错，提问。是的，谢谢。所以，提问。
所以我会问一个问题：可以有多少静默时间？我可以停顿多久？我数了7秒，对我来说，等待并且不说任何话，持续10秒或7秒，感觉像永恒，但那是标准的等待回答的时间。
当然，问题必须精心选择，不能太明显，否则人们会不好意思说出答案；也不能太难，否则没人有话可说。
所以这里有一些示例技巧，你可以把它们放进你的武器库，积累你关于演讲的想法。如果这能说服你，让你相信演讲确实有学问，那么我就
已经成功了，因为我想让你相信的是，如果你观察你敬佩的、觉得有效的演讲者，并问自己他们为什么成功，那么你就可以建立自己的个人技巧库，发展出
你自己的个人风格。这就是我的基本目标。这次演讲的其余部分将讨论我武器库中的一些我认为有效的东西。所以，我们议程上的下一项，当我们开始讨论其他事情时，
是时间和地点的讨论。那么你认为什么时候是演讲的好时间？上午11点。
是的，原因是大多数人在那个时候已经醒了，而且几乎没有人会再睡着。也不是饭后，人们不会因为这样那样而疲劳。那是个演讲的好时间。所以这就引出了下一个
问题，关于地点。地点最重要的是光线要好。
这个房间光线很好。其他类型的房间的问题是，我们人类，每当灯光变暗，或者每当房间光线昏暗，就表示我们应该睡觉了。所以无论我去哪里演讲，
即使是今天，我面对视听人员做的第一件事就是说：“把灯全打开。”哦，他们可能会回答：“如果我们关灯，人们会看得更清楚幻灯片。”然后我回答：“闭上眼睛很难看到幻灯片。”关于地点还有什么要说的呢？
好的，地点应该预先踩点。我的意思是指像“踩点”那样的感觉，比如如果你要抢银行，你会在之前去银行看看情况，
这样当你实施抢劫时就不会有意外。所以，每当我去某个地方演讲，我要求主人做的第一件事就是带我去我将演讲的地方，这样如果有任何怪异之处，我就能
处理它。有时候可能需要一些干预，有时候只需要我理解挑战是什么。所以今天早上我来这里时，我做了我通常会做的事：我想象所有的座位都坐满了
不感兴趣的农场动物。这样我就知道无论情况多糟糕，也不会比那更糟。所以最后，场地应该有一定的人数。
应该是这样：如果这个大厅里只有10个人，每个人都会想知道发生了什么，这比没人来有趣得多。所以你要找一个大小合适的场地，不一定
要挤满，但必须超过一半满。这些是关于时间和地点的一些想法。接下来我要谈的是关于白板、道具和
幻灯片。这些是演讲的工具。我相信，当你的目的是提供信息时，白板是正确的工具。幻灯片适用于展示，但当我提供信息、教学、讲课时，我使用白板。有几个原因：首先，当你使用白板时，你有图形的
特性。当你用白板时，你可以轻松利用在演示中使用图形的优势。这就是我喜欢的图形特性。其次，我喜欢速度特性。你在黑板上写字的速度
大约是人们吸收思想的速度。如果你快速翻一堆幻灯片，没人能跟上那么快。最后，白板的一个伟大特性是它可以是一个
很多演讲新手突然意识到自己的手的存在，好像手是私密部位，不该在公共场合露出来。于是他们立刻把手插进口袋，这在一些地方被视为不敬。
有时手会这样放在背后。我曾在塞尔维亚的一座修道院，一进门就有修女端来点心。
我正想说不用了，谢谢，但主人说，吃吧，不吃会死的。这是当地习俗和礼貌。但接着修女把我的手从背后拉下来，因为在那种文化里，手背在身后是极其无礼的。
为什么？通常认为这与是否藏了武器有关。如果手在口袋里或背后，可能看起来像藏了武器。这就是我说的白板的好处之一：现在你的手有事可做了，可以指向东西。我曾听西蒙·派珀特演讲，觉得太棒了。
所以我又去听了一次。第一次吸收内容，第二次观察风格。我发现派珀特不停地指着白板。我琢磨了一会儿，注意到他指的东西和他说的毫无关系。
但这是有效的技巧。所以这就是关于白板好处的一点。现在我想谈谈道具。关于道具，剧作家最懂。几十年前我看过一部易卜生的戏，叫《海达·加布勒》。我记得大概情节：一个女人婚姻不幸，她丈夫和别人竞争学术职位，但他快要输了。
部分原因是他无聊，部分原因是竞争对手刚写了一本巨著。顺便说，那是在复印机和电脑出现之前。戏开场时，有一个大肚炉子，炉门开着，里面有些微弱的余烬。但炉子一直在那儿，随着剧情紧张起来，你看到那份手稿，易卜生巧妙地运用了这个道具。
你感觉要出事了，因为随着剧情推进，火越来越大，越来越旺，最后吞噬一切。你预感到手稿会被扔进火里。这让人印象深刻，是我记住的剧情。所以剧作家深谙此道。
但并非只有他们能用道具。这里有个道具运用的例子，也出自西蒙·派珀特。他谈到用正确方式看问题的重要性，这个例子不仅教了这一点，还能让你在机械工程朋友面前让他们出丑。
做法是：拿这个自行车轮子，让它旋转起来，然后在轴上施加扭矩，或者对着边缘吹气。问题是它会往那边转还是往这边转。机械工程师会立刻说，啊，右手螺旋定律，然后他们摆出手势，但常常忘记怎么正确地将手指与问题的各个方面对齐。
所以他们通常答对概率只有50%。他们受的高等教育让他们达到相当于抛硬币的水平。但不必非要这样，因为你可以换个思路。做法是拿些胶带缠在轮子的一部分上，然后不要想整个轮子，只想胶带下面那一小块。
当那一块转过来到顶部时，你对着它吹口气，忽略轮子的其他部分。那块胶带下面的一小片会怎样？它肯定想往那边去，因为你在推它，它已经往下走了。那下一块呢？一样。所以唯一的结果就是轮子会那样倒下去。这样你永远不会再困惑，因为你用正确的方式思考问题。而且这可以用一个你能尝试的道具演示。
另一个我喜欢的例子来自我上801课的时候。当时讲师是艾伦·拉扎勒斯，他在讲能量守恒、动能和势能。天花板上有根长线，在26-100教室，系着一个更大的钢球，就像这个。拉扎勒斯把球靠在墙上，头贴着墙稳定自己，然后放手。摆锤要好几秒钟才摆过去再摆回来，然后轻轻碰到他的鼻子。
所以你有好几秒时间想：这家伙真信能量守恒。千万别在家试。问题是第一次做你可能不会只是放手，因为人有推一下的自然倾向。
这就是关于道具的一点。
道具，你知道吗，很有趣的是，每当进行调查时，学生总是说多用粉笔少用PPT，为什么呢？道具也总是非常有效，为什么呢？我会给你我疯狂边缘的观点，这与……
我所说的……
共情镜像有关。当你坐在那里看着我写在黑板上时，我相信你脑袋里那些小小的镜像神经元会被激活，你能感觉到自己在黑板上写字。甚至更多，当我谈论……
这个钢球往那边走，往这边走，你能感觉到那个球，就像你是我的样子。而用幻灯片做不到，用图片做不到，你需要看到它，在物理世界中看到，这就是为什么我认为……
哦，是的，当然，这里还有速度的问题，需要区分开来，但我认为共情镜像是道具和黑板使用如此有效的原因。好吧，让我们看看，哦，是的，还有一件事，关于……
工具方面，那就是幻灯片的使用。我重复一遍，我认为它们是为了展示想法，而不是为了教授想法，但我们在求职演讲或会议演讲中做的事情是展示想法，而不是教授它们。所以让我告诉你一些……
关于我对此的看法。我记得有一次我在洛根机场的A航站楼，刚从一个非常糟糕的会议回来，航班也很糟糕，是那种感觉像不平衡的洗衣机一样的航班，我一生中唯一一次……
决定在去车的路上停下来，喝杯咖啡放松一下。当我待了几分钟后，有人走过来对我说，你是温斯顿教授吗？我想是吧，我说我不知道，我想我是想幽默一下。无论如何，他说……
我要去欧洲做求职演讲，你介意看看我的幻灯片吗？我当然不介意，我说。他说，你幻灯片太多了，而且字太多了。你怎么知道的？他说，也许我之前看过你的演讲？我没有。我的回答是，因为总是这样，总是有太多幻灯片，总是有太多文字。所以让我给你展示一些极端例子，关于如何不使用幻灯片。为了这个演示，我……
需要站到这边来，当我到这边时，我可以开始说一些话，比如，你不应该做的事情之一是读你的透明幻灯片。你的听众会自己读，而你读出来只会烦他们。此外，你应该确保每张透明幻灯片上只有几个词，并且那些词容易读懂。我希望这让你抓狂，因为我正在犯各种错误，第一个是这张幻灯片上字太多了……
第二个是我站在那边，而幻灯片在那边，所以你就陷入了那种网球比赛的感觉，在幻灯片和演讲者之间来回切换。你想要幻灯片作为你所说内容的调味品，而不是主菜，或者反过来。那么怎么解决呢？第一步是去掉背景垃圾，那总是分散注意力的。第二步是去掉文字。当我把文字减少到这些……
然后我之前读的一切，我没有资格说，因为不在幻灯片上，我不再读我的幻灯片了，但我说的是之前例子中写在幻灯片上的内容。那么我们还能做什么来简化呢？我们可以去掉标志，我们不需要它们，简化。还能做什么？去掉标题。现在我想和你谈谈幻灯片制作的规则，我告诉你，标题不一定……
要放在上面。通过减少幻灯片上的字数，我让你更关注我，而不是关注幻灯片上写的内容。我之前提到过，我们只有一个语言处理器，我们可以用它来阅读或听讲者说话。所以如果幻灯片上有太多文字，就会迫使听众去读这些内容而不听。我的一个学生几年前做过一个实验，他教一些学生一些基于网络的编程……
想法，一半信息在幻灯片上，他说，另一半则在别处。然后对于对照组，他反过来。问题是，受试者，也就是他兄弟会的新生，他们记得最清楚的是他说的还是他们在幻灯片上读到的？答案是他们在幻灯片上读到的，当幻灯片上有大量材料时，他们不会注意演讲者。事实上，在事后报告中，其中一个受试者说……
我希望你少说点话，它很分散注意力。好吧，最后一个项目是消除杂乱，我听到一些杂乱，不，不，没理由，甚至那些项目符号也不需要。所以，文字太多的问题是微软犯下的罪行，因为它允许你使用太小的字体，所以你应该有一张这样的示例幻灯片，用来确定最小字体大小是多少。那很容易测量，你怎么看？哪个大小合适？那是什么？……
大小合适，是的，最小可能40或50。他说40或50，我觉得差不多，35就太小了，不一定是因为你看不清，而是因为你可能用它来在幻灯片上放太多文字。我们还有其他什么罪行？我们有激光笔罪行，不是那个。你知道，在过去没有激光笔的时候，我们用木制笔，人们会挥舞它们，很快就像……
一场旋转比赛。所以这是我在过去推荐的应对这种情况的方法。
这个例子是用道具的一个例子，吉姆·格拉斯，大约20年前我听过这个演讲，然后，哦，是的，我记得那次演讲，就是你把讲标弄断的那次，道具往往是最容易被记住的东西，真是令人惊叹。
现在，哦，我们已经没有实物讲标了，我们有激光笔，这真是个奇迹，没有更多人因为这个而癫痫发作，但这就是经常发生的情况，看那个，它是一张可爱的递归图片，我可以成为它的一部分，把激光束直接照在我的后脑勺上，你看到了什么？你看到我的后脑勺，我没有眼神交流，没有互动，什么都没有。有一次我和一个学生坐在一起看一个演讲，她说，你知道吗，我们都可以离开，他也不会知道。所以当你使用激光笔时会发生什么？你不可能不转头去指东西，当你那样做的时候，你会失去与观众的联系，你不想那样做。那么如果你需要指出图像中的某个东西，又不想用激光笔指，该怎么办呢？这就是你该做的：放一个小箭头在那里，然后说，现在看那个，第一个箭头末尾的那个人，你不需要激光笔来做这个。
当人们让我评价一个演示时，我让他们打印出来，摊在桌子上，当他们这样做时，很容易看出演讲是否太沉重，文字太多，空气不够，空白不够，图像不够。这是一个很好的例子，这样的演讲太沉重了，演讲者利用了小的字体大小，尽可能把更多的内容放在幻灯片上，这里有很多罪过，但太沉重是我想要说明的。所以与此形成对比的是另一个演讲，我几年前做的，不是技术性很强的演讲，但我给你们看是因为它有空隙，它主要是事物的图片，有三四张幻灯片上有文字，但当我到那些幻灯片时，我给观众时间去读，它们放在那里可能是因为它们有历史意义。第一张有很多文字的幻灯片是从1957年关于达特茅斯人工智能会议的提案中摘录的，这非常有趣，而从提案中摘录的历史片段有助于把这一点讲清楚。我们还有什么呢？哦，是的。
你们今天的词汇是“epexegesis”，这意味着这种幻灯片你在一次演讲中只能侥幸使用一次。这张幻灯片几年前有一些影响力，因为它展示了治理阿富汗的复杂性，通过展示它有多么复杂，这是你们观众无法理解的，而这正是重点，但你不能有很多这样的幻灯片，你可以在一个工作、一个演讲、一篇论文或一本书中只能用一次，这就是epexegesis的意思，这就是一个例子。我已经给你们看了一些罪过，所以你们可能会问，这些罪过真的会发生吗？它们确实会发生，有手插口袋的罪过，有时间和地点选择的罪过，这是你去巴托斯剧院的路，首先你要从媒体实验室那边的台阶下去，然后穿过这个大开放空间，然后右转进入这个走廊，这时候无论何时我进去，我都会想知道角落里是不是有刑具，然后当你进去，你会进入一个阴暗的地方，所以它被称为巴托斯剧院是名副其实的，因为那是一个你可以看电影的地方，但不是你可以做演讲的地方。现在，关于一个不在这里发生的主题，这是一次我前段时间在斯塔塔参加的演讲，注意演讲者离幻灯片很远，演讲者正在用激光笔，你会对我说，这里发生了什么？顺便说一下，这是演示中的第80张幻灯片，注意它充满了文字，这是10张总结幻灯片中的第一张。那么观众的反应是什么？那是会议的主办方，他在看电子邮件，这是会议的联合主办方，他在看午餐菜单，这个人呢？这个人看起来像是在注意听，但这是因为是一张静态图片，如果你看到视频，你会看到的是这样的东西。
所以，是的，这些罪过确实会发生。好了，那是对工具的快速回顾，现在我想谈谈一些特殊情况，我们可能稍微谈一下“告知”，或者换句话说，做我现在正在做的事情，但我会只说几句话。在那类演讲中，你想以承诺开始，就像我为这一个小时做的承诺一样，我们正在进行。但然后问题就来了，你如何激励人们？我做了这个演讲很长时间，几年前，我们的系主任说，请你把这个演讲给新教员讲，并强调如何激励学生。奇怪的是，我之前没有想过这个问题，所以我开始了一项调查，我与我的一些新生顾问交谈，并与资深教员以及介于两者之间的人交谈，关于他们是如何被激励的。我从新生那里发现，他们是被某个高中老师激励的，老师告诉他们他们可以做到；我从资深教员那里发现，他们是被某个帮助他们以新方式看待问题的人激励的；我从每个人那里看到的是，他们都被……
当有人对自己所做的事情充满热情时，这很鼓舞人心。对我来说这很容易，因为你知道我做人工智能，你怎么能对人工智能不感兴趣呢？
对吧？我的意思是，如果你对人工智能不感兴趣，那你可能对有趣的事情也不感兴趣。所以当我在AI课上讲课时，我自然而然地会谈论我认为酷的东西，以及某个新想法有多么令人兴奋。
这就是表达热情的方式，它能产生影响，同时也能传递信息。关于鼓舞人心，哦，当然，在这个承诺阶段，你还可以表达事物有多酷。让我给你举一个以这种方式开场的讲座例子。我在讲资源分配，这和你安排飞机航班、调度工厂等需要的思路是一样的，但例子是为美国各州涂色，相邻的州不能有相同颜色。所以，这是我在课堂开始时展示的内容。
这是一种涂色的方法，你可能会说，我们为什么不等到它完成呢？你想那样吗？不，我们不会等它完成，因为太阳会爆炸并吞噬地球，这个程序才会结束。但是，如果对程序的工作原理稍作调整——我告诉我的学生，你们将在接下来的50分钟内理解——这就是你得到的结果。是不是很酷？你知道，你得对这种计算感到惊叹，它从比太阳系寿命还长的时间缩短到几秒钟。
所以，这就是我所说的提前给出承诺，并对你谈论的内容表达一些热情。好了，这个小块里的最后一项是，它涉及到人们认为他们在MIT做的事情。你问一位教师最重要的目的是什么，他们会说，我做的最重要的事情是教人们如何思考。然后你说，哦，那太棒了，你是怎么教人们思考的？他们茫然地看着你，没有人能回答这个自然的后续问题。那么，如何教人们思考呢？我相信我们是讲故事的动物，我们从童年时的童话故事开始发展我们对故事的理解和操纵能力，并继续通过专业学校，如法律、商业、医学、工程等，我们一生都在这样做。
所以，如果这就是思考的全部，那么当你想要教人们思考时，你给他们提供他们需要知道的故事，他们需要提出的关于这些故事的问题，分析这些故事的机制，组合故事的方法，评估故事可靠性的方法。这就是我认为教人们思考时你需要做的。但那都是关于教育的，你们中的许多人来到这里不一定是为了那个，而是为了这个部分，为了说服，这分为几个类别：口试（未展示）、求职演讲、成名。关于口试，我不会说太多，除了它们过去比现在可怕得多。在过去，阅读外语文献是其中的一部分，而且失败率很高。当你回顾那些失败时，人们口试失败最常见的原因是未能定位和未能练习。所谓定位，我的意思是，重要的是把你的研究放在背景中讲，这是一个全世界都在研究的问题，在我之前的过去30年里没有任何进展，每个人都在寻找解决方案，因为它会对许多其他事情产生影响。所以，这是时间和地点以及领域的定位。至于练习，是的，练习很重要，但那并不意味着把你的幻灯片展示给与你共用办公室的人。问题在于，如果人们知道你在做什么，他们会幻觉你的演示中存在不存在的内容。顺便说一句，一个变体是你的导师，他不是一个很好的帮你调试演讲的人，因为他们实际上知道你在做什么，他们确实会幻觉你的演示中存在不存在的内容。所以，你需要找一些不知道你在做什么的朋友，让他们……你开始练习时说，如果你不能让我哭，我就不再把你当朋友了。然后当你去参加口试时，你就会觉得容易了。
你看，难度，你从某人那里得到的批评数量与年龄成正比，年龄越大，他们越了解自己在世界上的位置。但年轻人试图向老年人展示他们有多聪明，所以非常恶毒。所以，每当你有机会有一个满是白发的人的考试委员会时，那就是你想要的。好了，这只是关于我没有列出的东西的一两句话。让我们进入求职演讲的话题。所以，多年前，我在圣地亚哥的一个酒吧里，我是海军科学委员会的成员，我和我委员会的几个同事在一起，有来自科罗拉多大学的Dolores Eder，她让我嫉妒得想吐，因为她写了21本书，而我只有177本。另一个是来自德克萨斯大学的Bill Whelan，他是电磁学专家，他知道如何用轨道炮把钢杆穿透坦克装甲。这些都是有趣的人，所以我说，你们在找教员候选人时看重什么？不到一微秒，Dolores说，他们必须向我们展示他们有某种愿景，紧接着Bill说，
他们必须向我们展示他们做了什么
哦，听起来不错。我说，然后我问他们，候选人需要多长时间来确立这两点？你觉得呢，和他们的答案比比看。
五分钟。所以，如果你在五分钟内没有表达你的愿景，没有告诉人们你做了什么，那你就已经输了。所以你必须做到这一点，让我提一下相关的几点。
首先，愿景部分是关于人们关心的问题，以及你方法中的新意。
所以，问题是理解人类智能的本质，方法则是问是什么让我们与黑猩猩和尼安德特人不同。是仅仅数量上的差异，还是我们在某种连续的方式上更聪明一点？
还是我们拥有根本不同的东西，而黑猩猩和尼安德特人没有？答案是，是的，我们确实有不同之处。我们是符号生物，因为我们是符号生物，我们可以……
嗯，我们可以构建关于关系和事件的符号描述，我们可以把它们串联起来讲故事，而因为能讲故事，这就是我们的不同之处。这就是我的标准演讲，这就是我大多数关于我个人研究的演讲的开场方式。
如何表达你做了什么？通过列出解决该问题所需的步骤。你不必已经完成所有步骤，但你可以说，这就是需要做的事情。
举个例子，这就是需要做的：我们需要指定某种行为，我们需要列举出处理该行为的约束条件，我们必须实现一个系统，
因为我们是工程师，我们不认为我们理解了一个东西，除非我们能构建它。我们构建了这样一个系统，今天我们将向你展示它。那将是列举一系列步骤来实现愿景的例子。
然后如此这般，最后你通过列举你的贡献来总结。
这有点像这些步骤的镜像，有助于确立你做了什么。所以，这是一个做技术演讲的通用框架。今天只剩下几件事要做，成名是我们的下一个议程。
因为一旦你得到了工作，你需要考虑一下如何让你的工作得到认可。
首先，为什么你应该关心成名？我想过这个，与一次我参加的筹款活动有关，那是一个为拯救威尼斯免于下沉、避免艺术品被毁而筹款的活动，总之，
我当时坐在这里，JC坐在那里，那是已故的朱莉娅·查尔德。
随着夜晚的进行，越来越多的人来找朱莉娅签名或表达她改变了他们的生活，这样反复发生。最后我转向朱莉娅，
我说，查尔德女士，出名有趣吗？她想了一下，说，你会习惯的。但你猜我想到什么？你永远不会习惯被忽视。所以，这是个思考方式，你的想法就像你的孩子，
你不想让他们衣衫褴褛地走进世界。所以你要做的是确保你有这些技巧、这些机制、这些关于如何呈现你的想法的思考，这样它们就能被认可其内在价值。
这就是为什么关注包装是合理的事情。那么，如何让别人记住你呢？我喜欢称之为温斯顿之星，我即将阐述的每一项都以S开头。所以，如果你希望你的演讲想法被记住，你需要做的其中一件事是确保你的工作有某种象征符号。
这个“拱门”的例子实际上来自我很多年前的博士论文。
在那个时候，我的工作中，这个关于拱门学习的工作变得有点出名，我不知道为什么。直到很多年后，我才意识到，那个工作意外地包含了这颗星的所有元素。所以，
第一个元素是有一种象征，就是拱门本身。
接下来你需要的是某种口号，一种能成为工作抓手的短语。在这种情况下，这个短语是“一次学习”。之所以说一次，是因为我写的程序从每个呈现的例子中学到了明确的东西，
所以，在从一个基于这种配置的模型转变为不是基于这种配置的拱门时，程序学会了它必须在顶部。一次学习，这就是一个简单的口号。现在我们需要一个惊喜，
是的，惊喜是你不需要一百万个例子来学习某样东西，你只需要一个例子，如果你足够聪明地适当利用那个例子的话。这就是惊喜：从每一个例子中你都能学到明确的东西。
接下来一个要点是“突出观点”。
这里说的“突出观点”，不是指重要，而是指让观点脱颖而出。有趣的是，有些演讲有太多好点子，结果听众反而不知道重点是什么，因为哪个才是重点呢？所以你需要一个能脱颖而出的观点。
在这个例子里，脱颖而出的观点是“差一点就成功”的概念。
你看，这不是一个拱门，但差得不多，所以是“差一点就成功”。最后，你需要讲述你是如何做到的、它如何运作、为什么重要。这就是关于如何不一定要出名，但确保你的工作得到认可的一些内容。
好了，我们快结束了，因为现在我们到了最后一项，那就是如何收尾。说到这个，问题来了：最后一张幻灯片该放什么？最后的话该说什么？
所以，关于最后一张幻灯片，让我给你一些可能的例子。这个怎么样？你可能看到这个幻灯片，然后心想：“麻省理工学院有一千名教员，干得不错，但也不算多，因为除以一千就少了。”
所以，当你在演讲结束时展示一长串合作者名单，这有点让人失望，因为这意味着没人知道你做了什么重要的事。
你得认可你的合作者，对吧？那在哪里做呢？不是在最后一张幻灯片上，而是在第一张幻灯片上。这些都在第一张幻灯片上，这些是合作者。所以你不要把他们放在最后，不要用这样的幻灯片。这个怎么样？
这是结束演讲最糟糕的方式，因为这张幻灯片可以挂在那里20分钟，我见过这种情况发生。它浪费了空间，浪费了告诉听众你是谁的机会。那这个呢？
我经常看到，但我从没见过有人把它写下来。它也浪费了机会。哦天哪，更糟的是，所有这些幻灯片对你都没用，它们浪费了机会，让你无法告诉听众你是谁，无法留下深刻印象。
那这个呢？这个不错。一开始看起来可能不错，但问题在于：如果你说“这些是我的结论”，这些是合理的结论，但没人关心。他们关心的是你做了什么。
这就是为什么你的最后一张幻灯片应该标上“贡献”。这反映了我在那里说的，求职演讲应该像一个三明治，而最后一张幻灯片，即人们在提问和离开时看到的那张，应该包含你的贡献。这是我自己的标准演讲中的一个例子。是的，这是我最常讲的内容。这些是我通常演示的东西，我等人们读，然后最后的一个元素是“这就是我们从中得到的”。所以这是一个“贡献”行的例子。
现在，关于另一部分，你有了最后一张幻灯片，它是“贡献”幻灯片。但你需要告诉听众你讲完了。让我们看看几种可能。最后几句话，你可以讲个笑话。
没关系，等你讲完了，人们已经适应了你的声音参数，他们准备好听笑话了。有一次我和同事道格·莱纳特在奥斯汀的酒吧里，道格是个很棒的演讲者，所以我问：“道格，你是个很棒的演讲者，你的秘诀是什么？”他说：“我总是以笑话结尾，这样人们就以为整个过程都很有趣。”所以，笑话行得通。那这个呢？
“谢谢”这个，我不推荐。这是个软弱的表现。如果你以“谢谢”结尾，你不会下地狱，但这是软弱的表现。原因在于，当你说“谢谢”甚至“感谢聆听”，这暗示着大家是因为礼貌才坚持到现在，他们其实很想离开，但因为礼貌才撑到现在，你是在感谢这个。所以一旦热烈的掌声响起，你可以用嘴型说谢谢，这没问题。但你要做的最后一件事不应该是说“谢谢”。你可能会说：“难道大家不都是说谢谢吗？”但大家都做的并不一定是对的。我想说明一下，有些演讲可以不靠“谢谢”结尾。
我喜欢引用政治演讲，但我最近听到的不太好，所以我得追溯一下。这是克里斯蒂州长，某年共和党全国代表大会的主题演讲，这是他演讲的结尾。让我们看看他怎么做的：“大家齐心协力，我们将再次站起来，为了美国的伟大，为了我们的子孙后代。上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美国。”这是典型的祝福式结尾。
“上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美国。”我不想显得偏袒，所以我想我还是换到那一年民主党全国代表大会的主题演讲，由比尔·克林顿发表，他可是深知怎么演讲的：“如果你想要那个，如果你相信那个，你必须投票，你必须再次选巴拉克·奥巴马为总统。上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美”
现在注意看，我们稍微回放一下。我想让你们看到，在某一点上，他似乎在抿紧嘴唇，强迫自己不说谢谢，然后还有一处他做了个小敬礼。这次注意看这些。
如果这就是你们想要的，如果这就是你们所相信的，你们必须投票，必须重新选举巴拉克·奥巴马总统。上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美国。大家都在抿嘴唇，[掌声]
SL：嗯，我觉得那很不错。那我们从中能学到什么呢？我想我可以这样结束演讲：上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑理工学院，但可能效果不太好。不过你们能从中领会到的是，你不必说谢谢，还有其他方法。有趣的是，随着时间推移，人们发现了这一点，于是就有了一些常用的结束方式。
在天主教古老的拉丁弥撒中，结束语是“Ite missa est”，大致意思是“好了，弥撒结束了，你们可以回家了”。当然，在音乐会上，你知道，鼓掌的时机不是在歌曲结束时，而是当指挥走过去和首席小提琴手握手时。
这些就是表明活动结束的惯例。所以这些都是可选的方式，但还有一种可能，那就是你可以向观众致敬。
我的意思是，你可以表达对大家的时间和这个地方的重视。比如我可以说：在这里的时光非常愉快，看到你们在麻省理工学院所做的这些事，真是令人着迷。你们提出的各种问题让我感到兴奋和激励，真的很棒。我期待未来能多次回来。
所以这就是向观众致敬，你可以这样做。嗯，这就是我想说的。你们知道吗，我很高兴你们在这里，因为你们能来，说明你们已经明白，如何呈现和包装你的想法是一件重要的事情。我为此向你们致敬。
我建议你们下次再来，带上朋友一起。[掌声]